"Star Wars" fans rejoice: the Witches
of Dathomir have made their long-awaited
live-action debut! First introduced in
the now-Legends novel "The Courtship of
Princess Leia," the witches eventually saw
their entrance into canon territory when
they appeared in Dave Filoni's "Star Wars:
The Clone Wars." In the animated series,
the Daughters of Dathomir,
also called the Nightsisters,
amazed and baffled audiences by bathing in dark
side energy and wielding ancient magick powers;
the witches certainly weren't Jedi, but they
didn't fully align with Sith beliefs either.
Now, the witches and their crimson robes have
returned, in league with Grand Admiral Thrawn
no less. In the latest episode of "Ahsoka,"
the magick wielders are waiting on Peridea
for Morgan Elsbeth to arrive with her
retinue. There are three witches, and
"Star Wars" fans may want to know who the actors
are bringing these mysterious characters to life.
Bringing to life the Great Mother Aktropaw
is none other than Jeryl Prescott. Without
her scarlet robes and eerie makeup, longtime
"Walking Dead" fans probably recognize this
actor. Prescott was one of the core characters
in the show's first season. She portrayed Jacqui,
one of the first characters who stood up to
Carol's abusive husband, Ed. Jacqui perished at
the end of the season when she decided to remain
behind at the CDC, which was timed to explode.
In recent years, Prescott has taken prominent
recurring roles in shows like "All the Queen's
Men" and "Swamp Thing." The latter wasn't her
only DC project as she also was in an episode
of "Batwoman." Prior to that, she played in
episodes of "Shameless," "Scandal," and "NCIS: Los
Angeles." In 2014, she also guest-starred in five
episodes on Showtime's hit series, "Ray Donovan."
While "Ahsoka" may be the actor's
first time in a galaxy far, far away,
she is obviously no Padawan
when it comes to performing!
Jane Edwina Seymour portrays Lakesis, the
Dathomirian witch who informs Morgan Elsbeth
of Thrawn's incoming arrival. The actor was
very thrilled to join the "Star Wars" universe,
having frequently expressed her excitement on her
social media before "Ahsoka" debuted, writing,
"Excited for this to go to air...and very grateful
to be a part of this STAR WARS series,
I loved working on it in so many ways."
Seymour is no stranger to the world of
sci-fi, having recently appeared in two
episodes of "Star Trek: Picard"
as the Borg Queen. Before that,
Seymour took part in more grounded dramas
such as "Nova Vita," playing Dr. Perkins
and starring alongside names like
Titus Welliver and Dean Norris.
Eagle-eyed fans of Netflix's
"You" may also recognize her,
as she played a hilariously upbeat and sort
of inappropriate library goer who compliments
Joe Goldberg's child just a bit too much.
Thankfully, she only appeared in a single
episode in the show's third season, any longer
and she may have had to endure Joe's wrath.
Portraying Klothow, who appears
to be the leading Great Mother,
is video game legend Claudia Black. Longtime
gamers may have recognized Klothow's voice,
as the actor has been a part
of several iconic franchises.
Interestingly, Black's most famous voice role is
arguably that of Morrigan from Bioware's "Dragon
Age" series; Morrigan is a Witch of the Wilds
and one of the main companions in "Dragon Age:
Origins." Talk about perfect casting! The actor
also has roles in two "Mass Effect" games,
another signature Bioware franchise. Black
has also voiced roles for popular titles like
"Call of Duty," "Uncharted," and "Gears of
War." And that barely scratches the surface.
On top of her several gaming roles, Black
recently guest-starred in four episodes
of HBO's "The Nevers." In 2022, she leapt
into another live-action sci-fi project,
taking on the leading role
of Karla Grey in "Deus."
Aside from voicing countless
iconic video game characters,
Black is probably best known for her
early recurring roles on "Farscape"
and "Stargate SG-1," shows that are considered
absolute gems and staples in the sci-fi genre.